de meilleures conditions de travail
c'est ce que réclament les grévistes de
la stib
la société des transports intercommunaux
de bruxelles d'après l'entreprise ce
sont quatre chauffeurs de bus sur 5 et
près de 40% des chauffeurs de tramway
qui n'ont pas assuré leur service ce
lundi
conséquence une forte perturbation de la
fréquence de passage le personnel en
grève estiment que les mesures qui
accompagne le déconfinement dans les
transports ne leur permettent pas de se
sentir suffisamment en sécurité
clairement on est un vecteur de
transmission dans plusieurs villes on a
vu que les transports en commun en joie
un très grand rôle dans la propagation
du virus et c'est ce qui va se passer
malheureusement ici avec l'abandon des
quotas
nous avions maximum 23 personnes par
tram
maintenant c'est illimité donc les gens
normalement sont obligés de mettre le
masque quand on regarde dans un tram il
ya la moitié qui n'en n'ont pas donc ça
aussi on revendique on demande qui est
plus de contrôle dans les trams des
employés qui regrette également le
manque de soutien des syndicats dans
leurs démarches
on n'a pas compris pourquoi les
permanents syndicaux ne nous ont pas
soutenu on était 80 % d'agents à ne pas
vouloir reprendre le rythme de
maintenant on ne comprend pas pourquoi
ils nous ont pas suivis
du côté de la direction de la stib on
explique que la meilleure manière de
réduire le nombre de personnes dans les
véhicules
c'est d'augmenter leurs cadences les
syndicats ils ont compris que c'était
essentiel d'augmenter l'offre parce que
augmenter l'offre de transport c'est
aussi sécuriser nos voyageurs et nos
conducteurs se retrouver dans un bus où
il ya trop de monde parce qu'il n'y a
pas suffisamment de places disponibles
ou laisser des gens aux arrêts avec les
risques de frictions que ça peut causer
ce n'est pas non plus une bonne solution
nous voulons pas des transports tenu
qu'ils soient bond et nous voulons des
transports publics où les gens peuvent
respecter une distanciation social pour
ce faire il faut augmenter l'offre sans
accord entre la société de transport et
les grévistes
un bras de fer pourrait s'engager
certains conducteurs ont en effet promis
de poursuivre leur mouvement s'ils
n'obtiennent pas satisfaction